- [Lecturer] Where we left
off in the last video,
we saw a Muhammed being
born into a tribal Arabia.
He's born into a powerful
tribe, the Quraysh,
who are in control of Mecca.
But his early life is difficult.
His mother dies when he's six.
His grandfather who's taken charge of him,
dies when he's eight years old.
But he's able to, under
the care of his uncle,
become a merchant.
And at the age of 25, he marries
a wealthy merchant widower
named Khadija who is 15 years his senior.
Then we saw at age 40 in 610,
while meditating in a mountain
outside of Mecca, he receives
the first revelations
of the Quran, according
to Islamic tradition.
And he's skeptical of it at
first, but he's reassured.
And then he soon receives
many more revelations.
And within roughly three
years, he starts to preach
those revelations.
Now as we mentioned in that last video,
what he was preaching did not
sit well with his own tribe,
those who ruled Mecca, the Quraysh.
He was preaching a mono theistic tradition
based on Judaism and Christianity.
He was preaching that
there's no God but God.
But Mecca's power, it's
economy was based on people
making pilgrimages there to
worship the idols at the Kaaba.
So the Quraysh did not
like Muhammed's revelations
and they did not like these early Muslims,
and they persecuted them.
They killed them, they tortured them,
and we saw in 615 the
migration of some of Muhammed's
followers to Abyssinia,
the Kingdom of Aksum,
modern day Eritrea and Ethiopia,
to escape some of that persecution.
Things got worse for Muhammed.
We saw in that last video,
the death of his first wife
and up to that point, his only wife.
And this is where we start
to see a bit of turning point
for Muhammed and his followers.
In 620 and this is according
to Muslim traditions,
there isn't historical evidence for this,
and this is one of the
more metaphysical events
that we'll talk about in this narrative.
But according to the Islamic faith,
in 620 Muhammed has a
night journey from Mecca
to the farthest mosque,
which today is believed
by many Muslims to be the Al-Aqsa mosque,
which was built later in Jerusalem.
So right over here.
So a night journey according
to the Muslim faith,
to Jerusalem where he
ascended with Gabriel
to the heavens and he conversed
with some of the prophets of old.
And once again, this is
clearly a metaphysical thing,
but it's significant
event in the Muslim faith.
Now the Quraysh continued
to persecute Muhammed
and the early Muslims in Mecca.
We have some of them that are
now in the Kingdom of Aksum.
And Muhammed learns that
there's a community,
a growing community of Muslims
in the town of Yathrib,
who are starting to follow
Muhammed or his revelations.
And they come to him and they invite him
to come to Yathrib because
there's actually a lot
of fragmentation, there's waring tribes.
And they're seeking an outsider
to help bring some peace
and authority to this place
where there is already
a burgeoning Muslim community.
So in 622, you have the famous migration
of Muhammed and his followers to Yathrib.
Which is renamed Medina.
And Medina literally means The City.
And from then on it
really becomes the base
of Muhammed and the early Muslims.
And Muhammed, once he's in Medina,
he is no longer just a prophet.
He isn't just continuing
to have his revelations
according to Islamic tradition.
But he essentially rules
over Medina, and governs it.
So he's starting to become
both a political ruler
and a spiritual ruler.
Now the Quraysh in Mecca
are still not happy.
Because Muhammed is continuing to preach,
and he's continuing to get
more and more followers.
And so you start having, at
first, a series of skirmishes
between the armies of the Quraysh,
or the members of the Quraysh,
and some of the early Muslims.
But these skirmishes eventually
emerge into full on conflict.
And here are some of
the significant battles
that occurred between the Quraysh tribe,
remember that's Muhammed's own tribe,
and the early Muslims, the
early followers of Muhammed
and his revelations.
So most famously perhaps,
you have the Battle of Badr.
Because this is the first time
that you have a significant
confrontation between a very small,
you wouldn't even necessarily
call this an army,
a small group of Muslims,
roughly a little over 300
according to Muslim tradition,
versus 900 or a little over
900 on the Quraysh side.
And the Muslims are
outnumbered three to one.
But this results in a Muslim victory.
And so you can imagine the
early Muslims start to see
this as a turning tide.
They were able to defeat
the powerful Quraysh tribe.
Now the Quraysh weren't happy with that.
And roughly a year later
you have another battle
outside of Medina on Mount Uhud.
And once again, the Muslims,
which are now larger,
but they continued to
be outnumbered even more
than three to one, this
is closer to four to one
right over here.
And this results in a Quraysh victory.
This is right over there.
Outside, on the northern side
of what is now called Medina.
But then a few years later
you have a significant battle.
Where the Quraysh have
built a confederacy.
And they wanna end the
teachings of Muhammed,
they wanna end these
Muslims who are threatening,
who's preachings are
threatening the pilgrimage,
the legitimacy of the
Quraysh tribe in Mecca.
And so they laid siege
to the city of Medina.
And as a defensive measure,
the Muslims in Medina,
create a trench around the city.
And that's why this is called
the Battle of the Trench.
And once again, according
to Islamic tradition,
the Muslims are outnumbered three to one.
So this is right over here,
the Battle of the Trench.
In which the Muslims are victorious.
And this is a significant
blow to the legitimacy,
the prestige of the Quraysh tribe.
A year later, you have
the Treaty of Hudaybiyyah,
between the Quraysh and the Muslims.
And this is significant
because it's starting
to put these early Muslims
on the same footing
as the powerful Quraysh tribe.
It has some allowances for the
Muslims to make pilgrimages
to the Kaaba.
But then as we go into 630,
there's an incident in which
one tribe kills some
members of another tribe.
Remember we're still in
a very tribal society.
And the other tribe, the one
that had some members killed,
was aligned, was friendly
with the early Muslims.
So the early Muslims
did not appreciate this.
They send an ultimatum to the Quraysh.
And the Quraysh essentially
say well that doesn't matter,
we don't really take what
you have to say seriously.
And they take one of the
options of the ultimatum,
which is making the Treaty
of Hudaybiyyah null and void.
So now that the treaty is
not there, and once again,
this is according to Muslim traditions,
which are our main accounts
that we have of this time.
We then have in 630, 10000 Muslims,
which is a very significant number.
Remember only six years ago,
we're talking about only 300
Muslims in the Battle of Badr.
But 10000 Muslims march on Mecca.
And they're able to take
the city peacefully.
And what this results in is
essentially most of the city,
converting to Islam.
And famously Muhammed goes into the Kaaba
and destroys the idols there.
And according to Islamic tradition,
makes the Kaaba a center
of the Muslim faith.
And it is even today.
Now from that point, the
spread of Islam continues.
You have Muhammed and his
armies, this green area
is essentially what they
were able to conquer
in the remainder of his life.
He lives for another two years after
the acceptance of Islam by Mecca.
And they're able to conquer
most of this dark green area
here and as we'll see,
shortly after his death,
most of Arabia and even Persia,
and within a few hundred years,
a large chunk of the world were able
to be conquered by these Muslim armies.